ladies and gentlemen boys and girls kids
of all ages it's time for the Big Show
please give a nice huge round of
applause for the man of the night
grandma
sorry I'm a big germaphobe I don't know
where that guy's been
um yeah when the pandemic first hit a
friend of mine always makes fun of me
he's like oh Graham you germaphobes you
must be freaking out I was like no this
is our finest moment
so nice to be here thank you uh Chicago
for coming out tonight
you better be outperforming again you
know it's been a crazy it's been a crazy
couple of years covet I think right you
know we all went a little nuts during
covet we all went little nuts it's okay
well some people went more nuts than
others
you know heard some crazy [__] like
masks don't work
really all right have your dentist cough
into your mouth
yourself a freedom flu you know what I
mean that'll be fun
last year when the vaccine came out
there's a lot of debate over it which is
good we should you know have questions
about the vaccine I get it you know but
I see all these comedians that I've
known for years on social media like I'm
not putting that into my body
I worked with you in Vegas in the 90s
I saw you do blow off a stripper's ass
okay you can hand a little moderna you
know what I'm saying
you're having a comedy club Pizza yeah
you can handle
trust me
it's 22 to see how things change you
know remember when it first hit America
everybody was working together remember
oh we ought to protect the most
vulnerable you know thank you front line
workers and we all banged our pots and
pans at eight o'clock for the medical
staff remember that I was like oh that
lasted three months
I'm reminded of World War II where the
Nazis bombed England every day for three
years and the British every day like Air
Raid Sirens like just a Hellfire from
above
every day the Brits are just like stiff
up a lip carry on
America's like I can't get a haircut
oh
I learned a lot you know especially when
the shutdown first happened I'm single
living alone and I learned during that
time that when I complained to my
friends that were married with kids
about how lonely and isolated I felt
they didn't give a [__] at all
they didn't care at all oh it's so hard
about being alone in your apartment you
don't have your spouse and your kids
crawling up your ass every day
my kid was late to zoom School how the
hell does that happen
oh he's about to win on a bike ride
along
I wish I was alone in my apartment
crying in the dark at least it would
have been quiet
oh thanks I guess I'll just rewrite my
suicide note
appreciate your support
dating during the pandemic's been hard
right any single people here tonight
see
three
before the pandemic half the crowd would
be like
the quarantine hit and everybody just
paired up and the music stopped and I
didn't have a chair you know what I'm
saying
like
it's hard
you know you tell them you the handful
of single people that are here I'm sure
when you you know talk to your friends
that are married with kids well it's
hard to meet someone do they always tell
you this [__] like you just gotta
love yourself
fall in love with graham you know
take Graham out on a date
that's a great idea you know
if I could suck my own dick but anyway
I mean I do yoga but I'm trying like I
can't
also I'll be honest you know having some
trust issues because like any good
professional comedian a couple years ago
had a horrifying breakup and thank you
so much and
yeah that was I was gnarly man I was
with this person for two and a half
years we lived together everything was
going great then it just went just went
nuts like I don't know what happened is
that ever happened to you like oh you
think everything's going great and then
just bam you're in the middle of a pink
song like
know what happened and I don't you know
I don't drink I'm completely sober and
she's like oh Graham I love that you
don't drink you're the best boyfriend
ever and then the last two months she
just went off the rails I went nuts and
a friend of mine she goes wow Graham you
know she was a woman in her 20s she was
a lot younger that's what happens I was
like what do you mean is this like a
thing that like every woman in their 20s
does this I didn't know I mean I did
some dumb [__] in my 20s but I wasn't
like that much of a train wreck you know
is that a thing like every girl yeah
every girl in her 20s blows up a two and
a half year relationship by becoming a
violent Coke or
boyfriend didn't get a restraining order
against you you weren't living
and I know some of you think oh Graham
you know you probably picked it no I I
get that there's guys out there that
deliberately date some girl that's
obviously a train wreck and then when
she goes nuts they act shocked that
wasn't one of those dudes it's like I
was dating this
through with a Coke problem and she just
wouldn't know
[Applause]
she just went off the rails here's
something I've you know kind of a
sidebar uh never heard anybody say
before is you know once I started doing
cocaine my life got better
they're making everything kind of evened
out you know what I'm saying better
group of friends the cocaine crowd good
solid people you know Dependable on time
no trouble with the law at all
another thing that makes dating hard is
uh my where I'm at politically
um many of you watch my YouTube show
political vigilante right on
thank you I have another show government
secrets those are thank you thank you
for those of you don't know they're just
kind of fun sort of loosey-goosey shows
kind of talk about how the Deep State
kill candidate you know just fun sorta
Trump and the clintons have ties to
Epstein you know just kind of fun silly
sort of the world's run by a global sex
trafficking billionaire pedophile ring
but other than that it's sort of a sign
of a spring break rom-com kind of a fun
so yeah it's I you know people like are
you on the apps no I'm not on the apps
they don't have a box to check for when
they're like What's your political when
you're filling out the profile they
don't have one that's anti-war pro-labor
socialist they don't have that
and when you do shoot somebody in the
back one whoa yeah there's one of us
just in the back can't pay your bills
because you're an activist
s thank you
when you do shows like political
vigilante and government secrets even
when if I do go on a date it's just hard
I'm too I'm too judgmental you know I'll
be like oh what do you do for a living
oh I work in the marketing department at
Google oh that's cool they've just been
doing data collection for the
intelligence Community for 2011 but
whatever
thanks for being part of the problem
this state's over check I'm done
yeah when you have a show called uh
political vigilante and government
secrets people send you crazy [__] in
the mail
like crazy
I've always had a PO Box on my website
and I saw the difference and to be fair
I've gotten some wonderful letters from
people like Graham I love your show it
got me through a tough time or you
opened my eyes up to something that the
regular people aren't regular media is
not talking about and I'm like oh that's
cool and to see the difference I
remember when I used to do a podcast
called comedy film nerds and
that's why we don't do it anymore
because
six people listen but thank you so much
nerds um but it was a fun show it was
very just nerdy we just nerded out about
movies we love doing it so people would
send me these kind of fun books when we
did comedy filmers like Star Wars trivia
and hey Graham I live in Pittsburgh
here's a book of all the cool movies
shot in Pittsburgh oh that's awesome and
now that I'm doing all this political
stuff I just get books like Sesame
Street and the CIA
oh Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy ran a
Honey Trap in El Salvador
it's cool doing that doing the the
podcast stuff because I have I have fans
of all different walks of life all
different age groups I mean from
teenagers all the way up to people in
their 80s people from all over the
country and all over the world it's
really amazing and so when I see uh like
people in my age group are older like
get mad the Millennials in the Genji I'm
like come on they're always looking
they're avocado toast in there
participation medals or whatever like
first of all who raised them
um
and like they didn't raise themselves
they didn't just come out and then the
other thing and here's what you say
anybody young tonight is it like in your
20s or 30s and and when you hear that
[__] like yeah
here's what you say like oh yeah it's so
awesome being young in America it's so
great can't afford College if we do go
to college I got crushing student loan
debt can't afford a house we're afraid
to have kids because of climate collapse
there's no good jobs out there we can't
afford health care if they're the only
jobs are like oh we have to have three
jobs delivering food and working for
Uber if we do get a good job it's with
some Silicon Valley billionaire [__]
with venture capitalist money creating
[__] or or that Silicon Valley are
those billionaires they creating cool
stuff to end homelessness and stop
climate collapse no it's always some
stupid like cat food home delivery app
cat snack chat app
now snack
laughs
so I like I said I grew up here but I I
live in Los Angeles now and uh when you
come from the Midwest and you move to
L.A there's a lot of cool stuff about
California but they have a there's some
stuff you're like what come on no one
would ever talk that way in a million
years but so
I'll give you a a statistic you might
not be aware of Los Angeles has the
highest percentage of people per capita
that use the following sentence 100
seriously
just manifest it
all the time just manifest it you can
take a chakra Crystal and think it you
can make anything happen
make it believe like wow there's all
these white ladies with special powers
it's amazing holy [__]
I'm like look I'm all for thinking
positive but let's be honest there's a
lot of first world privilege in the
manifesting
the home is not like oh the homeless
should just manifest not living in late
stage capitalism
and manifest moving to Beverly Hills
so I did that joke in La recently and
after the show this woman came up to me
and she was a manifestor
she was all like look Graham you know it
works and I'm telling you I don't care
anymore she was all fired up
some white lady with a Hindu name for
Karen or whatever
[Laughter]
she's just like you know Grand
manifesting works I mean I did it that's
how I manifested having my own clothing
store
oh the one your parents helped you with
that's what I forgot to do manifest a
trust fund okay
but she wouldn't let it go she's like
well look at you Graham you manifested
being a professional comedian
and I was like all right I'll give you
that yes I did I've worked long and hard
I started at this club Zanies that's why
it's amazing that I'm here I mean yes
right
after the show you go back there and see
my picture on the wall when I'm 22 I
have a vest over a t-shirt
uh and thankfully you it's just from the
waist up so you can't see my acid wash
jeans but anyway
90s were complicated time you guys it
was a complicated time for everybody but
no that's
that's why being you know yes I I've
worked long and hard and that's why I
wanted to shoot my special at this club
because as I'm from Chicago and this
this is one of the first places that
ever worked me and this club is over 40
years old it's an amazing Club it used
to be a strip club run by the mob so
it's like
it's probably a mob hit here you know
it's got that Vibe you know what I mean
but I said to this woman said you're
right you're right I did manifest
becoming a professional comedian but
let's be honest folks I'm lucky I live
in a country where this is even a job
right come on
third world countries you don't get to
just pick jobs and make up some crazy
career there's not a guy in Yemen right
now going this horrifying proxy war
between Iran and the evil American
Empire at the behest of the brutal
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia causing a worse
humanitarian crisis the world has ever
known but I'm sure it will end once
Mercury gets out of retrograde
[Applause]
then I will manifest my vision board
dream of owning my own pilates studio
#blessed
so I had a college professor father and
anyone who's had college professor
parents knows that when you're a kid
everything is a learning experience
this was never more evident than when my
family I'm the youngest of four we lived
in Germany for a year my father had a
Fulbright which is a research
scholarship and his PhD was in German
Theater history
and yes that's a lot of fun when you're
a kid
learning about Gerta and bertold brecht
those guys were all right
my friends are going to amusement parks
I was learning about German
existentialism
living in Germany in the 70s was a blast
too because it was only 30 years after
World War II so the German kids [__]
hated us
and it was a just unreal was like oh man
the Germans are mean you know no fun
happening oh actually that's not I
should meet that's stereotypical that's
stereotypical because we all know the
name the very famous German comedian
yeah there isn't one folks
there wasn't one there never has been
one there never will be one it's not
happening no such thing
so the entire year we lived in Germany
all we did was go to museums and castles
I'm like doesn't this country have a
water park or some [__]
so one of the field trips the
educational field trips my dad took us
on was we all went to Dachau
that's a concentration camp folks
here was the age breakdown my oldest
sister was 14. so it's all right it's
probably the age you should start
learning about the Holocaust and you
know the realities of the world my other
sister was 11. okay my brother was nine
that's too young I was six
was a little young dad all he said was
well I guess we didn't really think that
through like
I became jaded early on
when we moved back to the States the
first day it's going again I'm like in
the second grade the teachers going
around the classroom like what did
everybody do on their summer vacation
like Timmy what did you do oh my dad and
my brother and I we built a go-kart oh
Susie what did you do oh I learned how
to make a campfire in the Girl Scouts
Graham what did you do I went to a death
camp
I don't trust the human race
there's no God
well why don't you just make that into
some macaroni art for show and tell
maybe like a turkey hand that just says
there's no God
can do different crayons for each one
so I have this dark view of the world
it happens every day you know people
will come to me oh Grant you must be a
Canadian he's your Canadian must watch a
lot of funny movies and TV shows
nope
I watch documentaries about cults
those are amazing you guys
here's why you gotta watch cult
documentaries
if you're ever having a bad day
maybe beating yourself up over some
decisions you made I can assure you
you've never done something as dumb as
join a cult
halfway through every cult doc I'm like
how stupid are these people
it's always so obvious
I mean all right it starts with Noble
intentions right it's a bunch of hippies
we're gonna live off the grid and grow
our own food and make our own clothing
and no more capitalism no more war it's
like oh yeah that sounds great but then
there's these obvious red flags
like matching outfits
come on like let's say you two guys who
are here cheating on your wives together
if you showed up late and walked in and
I was wearing a robe with a sash and the
whole crowd was wearing a matching robe
you'd be like oh where's the comedy show
not the cult rally you just sat next
door the comedy said okay okay
the leaders of the Colts always have
crazy eyes and jacked up haircuts it's
so obvious there's one on HBO this woman
Gwen she's got this huge like tidal wave
blonde hair and she's like Jesus wants
you to give me ten thousand dollars to
lose weight
it's so obvious but even years later the
people are being interviewed still
sounds so dumb and clueless
they're always like well you know one
day we were all doing yoga and the
prophet walked in
and he stuck his thumb in my butt
[Applause]
and I thought this is kind of weird
and then he said the second knuckle
brings enlightenment
so I mean who could have known
everyone knew
so we gotta come to grips with the fact
that
we all grew up in America which is a
cult
America's a cult guys we have to admit
we're a cult we have to admit we're
really I used to think America's the
greatest country in the world it's not
perfect but no it's a cult we're not
number one in any good category at all
you know what I mean we're the only
categories we're good and are bad like
we're number one in prison population
number one in gun deaths number one in
infant mortality amongst Western Nations
we're number one in military spending
like
yeah exactly the categories we should be
number one like infrastructure I just
looked it up today we're 13th
we're number 13. we're number 13.
take that Denmark you 14th Place suck
holes like
so America you know we've got all these
little Cults within us are too political
both our political parties are Cults our
religions are most of them Cults you
know
oh yeah
this is why I love my [__] YouTube
podcast fans because they don't Heckle
they just bring up political
clarifications it shows
actually most of them if you look into
it by definition
um I love it I don't want to get heckled
at these shows it's just like Graham
actually that ballot measure passed by
two-thirds vote like
thank you appreciate it
yeah but that's why comedians we'd never
fall for Cults you've never heard of a
professional comic getting roped into a
cult because we have been in the back of
classroom since we were kids going this
is [__]
comedians don't fall for calls Comedians
and black people black people don't fall
for cults
right there I was like what the [__]
although I did that joke recently and a
black woman yelled out the Baptist
Church and I was like oh yeah that's
black people call okay cool
I get it I don't get offended folks I I
know all about religious cults I was
raised Catholic
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so we have to understand America's
occult right we've got all these little
Cults within us you know like Florida
is a cult
I don't know what is happening in
Florida I don't know what they're doing
down there I'm going to read you an
actual story because I file on the
Reddit there's a Reddit page called the
Florida man so it's amazing this is an
actual story I am not making this up you
can look this up online this is not I'm
not exaggerating this at all this is a
real title and I clicked on it
nude beach [__] jet ski fight
[Applause]
leads to wife's death
what's going on Florida what are you
doing Florida
and I feel like if somebody came from
another country and didn't know anything
about America
and just had an iPhone and said hey Siri
what's Florida
Siri would just be like nude beach
[__] jet ski fight
coupon book Clan rally park hopper pass
kids eat free alligator flip-flop Casino
glow in the dark sun visor Bingo AARP
discount beach volleyball Red Lobster
neon airboat strip club orange juice gun
show college football affordable Senior
Living Hooters three t-shirts for ten
dollars all you can eat Oxycontin spring
break Burn Notice swap tour
thank you Siri
and I don't know
people that grew up there because I know
I've been I've performed in Florida
bunch I've had great shows there and
I've met people that grew up there they
seem Smart Sharp people although my ex
is from there oh God I should have known
she had a pentagram tattoo and a drug
problem anyway I made a mistake
um
yeah
but that aside
um I think the I've met a lot of people
from Florida and they seem pretty sharp
I think what happens
a Florida attracts
every like American that's run out of
options
when you're in Florida ask who moved
there go why did you move not I mean
obviously this you know we went to
retire not the retirees that's a
different thing but just the people who
moved there in the middle of their lives
there's always some shady reason why
nowhere else in America has this you ask
anyone why'd you move to Chicago oh my
wife got a new job or we moved to Dallas
to be closer to my parents it's like
why'd you move to Florida hey you know
the courts up in Massachusetts or
[Applause]
oh oh it's the quartz is it oh okay yeah
that's why you're renting out jet skis
and dealing oxy on the side it's an
all-cash business under a fake name got
it yeah yeah it's the courts they really
total Court thing
so we have to come to grips with
the fact
that America is the Florida of Earth
I got friends all over the world I was
just in Europe for two two and a half
weeks I went to six different countries
and all I heard was what's [__] wrong
with you guys over there
what are you guys doing
and in all fairness we have to come to
grips with the fact that maybe
the human race like maybe Earth is the
Florida of the Galaxy you know what I'm
saying
they never land and
[Applause]
they never they just fly by
why can't a UFO just land and get out of
this patient well how are you we're from
another place you guys from Earth it's
nice
they're terrified of us
and I think this is my theory I think
UFOs are actually alien teenagers
borrowing their parents spaceship
their parents are like you do you can
use your father's spaceship but do not
go to Earth okay
your uncle went there in the 50s he's
been in Area 51 they've been sticking
stuff in his ass ever since
do not go
no no we're just gonna go to Chad's and
do homework
how does these alien teenagers you know
and there's like a younger brother in
the back who's never been to Earth and
they're like
we gotta go to Earth
my mom said we should no dude it's
awesome you got to watch these people
they're out of their minds
they kill each other over money and oil
and religion they're out of their
[__] minds
they draw lines in a map and go that's
your country this is mine and then
[__] kill each other and fight over
that [__] foreign
they need breathable air and drinkable
water to survive but they poison it for
money it's [__] stupid
they worship billionaires what's a
billionaires just Rich [__] and [__]
everybody over they're so goddamn
[__] stupid there's no we got to see
this [__] but you they got the best weed
so yeah I want you know I want to have
faith in America and the world can fix
that [__] I want to have faith that we
can fix stuff you know I I have uh you
know I just want things equal I like
equality that's why I don't you know
great thank you so much right just equal
like the idea of what America was
supposed to be right equal
representation I mean aside from the
genocide and slavery but other than that
just want things equal but I see little
there's little glimpses of hope you know
I mean the black lives matter that's
been good for people and black people
getting uh you know ending systemic
racism all these young people out there
unionizing there's been over 200
Starbucks unionized like that's that's
good labor you know women are getting
equal rights that's amazing it's
[__] that anyone should tell them
what they could do with their [__]
rights and bodies that's [__]
nonsense
come on
this guy here of a bunch of women told
us what to do with our dicks we'd be
like [__] that
I mean I know there's some married guys
are like well my wife's got my dick in a
jar but that's
I'm all for equality I just want it to
be equal but I must say this there are
some women out there not a lot some some
of these feminists who just want
equality for the good [__]
oh got quiet did it yeah
you know there's just a certain type
we'll just call them I don't know
Hillary supporters anyway
um
and you know because I I've never seen
this I've never seen like Deborah
Messing or one of those big celebrity
feminists like it's protesting like I
it's I'm so tired that I have to get a
good paying job and this nice
air-conditioned office when what I
really want to do is work on a garbage
truck
it's not fair that guys get to work in
garbage and 92 of all workplace deaths
are man that's [__] more men are in
prison that's unfair more men are
homeless that's [__] we gotta do
something about that
men have a higher suicide rate come on
ladies we gonna even that [__] up
patriarchy you know
laughs
so when Russia invaded the Ukraine
it's going to get dark folks Buckle the
[__] up
I'm glad you guys are down because
those of you who are like huh just
don't ever take your kids to Dachau
anyway
um
this is what happens
so when Putin invaded the Ukraine
Ukrainian President zielinski ordered
all men under the age of 60 to stay and
fight women and children could leave men
had to stay even men that were like yo I
make shoes they're like here's a machine
gun you make war now [__] like
I didn't see any of these women on
social media like president zielinski is
a sexist it's toxic masculinity women
should be allowed
women should be allowed to fight in a
[__] proxy war for money just like
men yes
come on ladies we're all flying to the
Ukraine with our [__] hats to fight the
Russian army
[Applause]
yeah I didn't see that online I didn't
see that
so yeah I don't I don't like you know
I'm against all War I don't like what
Putin is doing I don't like it I'm
against War main reason because uh I
have been to Iraq and Afghanistan to
entertain the United States military if
there's any military or vets here
tonight give them a round of applause
folks
you know we have an all-volunteer
military because of economic
conscription so I've seen you know
Stroup
um and uh you know I I've seen you know
I've been on a I don't know what real
Combat is like and I'll never know uh
but I've seen more war than most
civilians have I've been on a helicopter
in Afghanistan that came under Fire I
had a rocket attack in Iraq I've seen
way too many uh wounded service members
and civilians and so I'm just against
War I'm just against it I'm done with it
I don't want to see that [__] anymore
yeah
so I get a little pissed off when I see
politicians in both parties in our media
getting this selective outrage like well
Putin's committing war crimes okay we
should hold him accountable but I don't
know uh has he been bombing the Middle
East for the last 20 [__] years no I
don't think he did right like
you know it's it's like we're all going
on and they see these celebrities at
Hollywood award shows like I stand with
the people of Ukraine the people of Iraq
Afghanistan Yemen Syria Palestine
Somalia I can't really stand for them I
got a bad back my knees a little Tweaky
you know
and it's so hypocritical man I can't I
can't watch it I can't we've we've spent
you know look at Afghanistan in 20 years
four presidents from both political
parties spent 3.5 trillion dollars to
replace the Taliban with the Taliban
the [__] was that for
the big winners were the Taliban and
defense contractors like yeah all right
Meanwhile we're number 13 in
infrastructure we're number 13.
so I just can't we're so hypocritical
man when I hear the politicians and the
people in the media say this without
acknowledging what we do it's literally
like a drug addict with face tattoos
running a meth lab out of a preschool
walking into a bar going you guys drink
too much
[Applause]
and it's always like you know endless
spending on war anytime we want
something good like how we need Medicare
for all we need free insurance health
insurance like they've had in Europe for
80 years
but then we're always told
how are you gonna pay for it like I
don't know the same way you pay for all
these wars and Wall Street bailouts like
how about that like they never run out
of money for those [__]
it's like when the Mississippi water
thing happened the governor Mississippi
said we need roughly three billion
dollars to fix our water on that same
day we spent another three billion to
Ukraine we sent over 70 billion thus far
and I'm like wow America is the worst
roommate ever
the American people they're like the
good roommate you don't pay your bills
on time like hey I borrowed your car
returned it I washed it and filled up
the tank and the United States
government with both of these parties
doesn't matter who's in charge they're
the worst roommate ever it's like the
good roommate comes in hey man did you
see that envelope remember I put that
envelope and I put three billion dollars
in there and it said to fix
uh Mississippi's water and I said just
don't spend it on anything else it's do
you know where it's gone I don't see
where it is oh [__] dude that was yours
oh man
Vegas
and then this guy zielinski came up and
we gave her to him and he started
shooting like you wasted that money in
Vegas dude the dice got cold don't blame
the messenger
here's how you end War
get everybody in Congress in the Senate
get every uh CEO of every defense
contractor everybody in the White House
the vice president the president
regardless if it's Democrat Republican
whoever's there the entire cabinet all
of the CEOs of the oil companies and the
CEOs of the banks that profit from war
have all of their children have to go to
war
yeah when Rich Kids go to war instead of
working class kids that's when war will
end I guarantee you I guarantee you you
know what I mean when like some rich kid
you know just like oh Ivanka Trump and
Hunter Biden are neck deep in the [__]
in Kiev
all right
I bet your war is going to end
when Chelsea Clinton and Donald Trump Jr
are drafted for Marine Corps boot camp
that's when Mommy and Daddy are going to
get a call like we go to Edward all
right pumpkin as soon as we leave
Epstein's Island we'll come there
so I think we all need to try travel
more as especially as Americans because
one of the things you notice with Cults
they isolate their members right they
keep them isolated from the outside in
America we're isolated we only share a
border with two countries I was just in
Europe I hit six countries in 15 days
all these different cultures and people
and everything we need to get out there
and travel right see the world see
what's out there get out of your comfort
zone man meet other people from go to a
country you don't speak the language
I've been to Russia I went there in 2019
and a friend of mine was Russian told me
I don't speak any Russian it's like just
put a ski at the end of every word
so I was in a coffee shop there was a
little cooler of pre-made sandwiches and
they had stickers on them but it was all
in Russian and I don't know what it said
at all so I call this woman over that
worked there she didn't speak any
English I just called her over and I
pointed at the sandwiches and I went
because I'm a vegetarian I went
vegetarianski
and she went ah da and then picked out
the sandwich
we figured it out our governments don't
get along but she got me a vegetarian
sandwich
at the Starbucks ski or wherever I was
at
we figured it out man get out there meet
people because it doesn't listen to what
the government say like I did a whole
tour through China and Japan right it
was amazing and you learn stuff about
different cultures like when you fly in
a major airline from an American city to
to another city in another country those
those big Airlines do a very good job of
making announcements in English right
but I then went from Hong Kong to do a
show in Guangzhou China and I flew there
like Spirit Airlines
it was like I don't know Dragon foot
Airlines or some [__] like that
and so when the plane lands I'm the only
Westerner that has probably ever been on
that flight
so when it lands they make an
announcement in Mandarin then Cantonese
then I don't know it sounded like like
Korean Japanese Sanskrit I don't know
by the time they got to English they
didn't give a [__] if it made sense
it was just like with kindest requests
of the pleasantries for the
travelmitness of your disembarkation for
your passporting
oh passport passport passport
so the whole trip is me just going oh
okay the whole trip was like that but I
learned and people laughed and we got to
know each other and we spoke four words
to it it was awesome right I learned all
this cultural stuff like when I was
going to Hong Kong a comedian friend of
mine said in Hong Kong that you can get
a hand tailored silk suit for like two
three hundred dollars that's a two three
thousand dollar suit in the states I'm
like awesome and all the street
merchants in Hong Kong know this so when
they see a western man walking down the
street they come at you and they have
this hand gesture that I was not
familiar with so in America when we call
someone over we do this right we go hey
yo yo come here come here I'm doing a
show with chakra crystals in a strip
club that used to be run by the mob
so in in China and large portions of
Asia they they do this hand gesture this
means call you over so I didn't know
that right so the guys he's like ah you
want silk suit and I thought he was like
get the [__] out you know what I mean
I was like [__] my bad I didn't vote for
him you know I vote third party like
and these guys Hard Sell you man he's
like ah you want silk suit you want fake
Rolex you want hashish I'm like this
guy's got everything
this is like a Walmart this is amazing
and then his store was teeny it was like
smaller than this stage and he's like I
can get you anything you want so I was
being a you know cocky American I was
going to try to stump him I'm like okay
how about a unicorn
yeah yeah yeah yeah no problem I just
took a carrot glued it on a cat's head
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so then I went to this outdoor Market in
Beijing and they had this wall of iPhone
covers and it was like all of the
rejects like all the stuff that doesn't
get sold in America they just unload it
there because you know everything's made
in China thanks to the bushes and the
clintons so anyway everything's there
and they not a lot of them didn't even
make sense
like one of them was trying to say I
heart
the USA
and the heart was an outline of the
continental United States but it had
stars and stripes on it and I was
looking at it like
I America the USA
like I don't know I wish I could show it
to you guys but it was for an iPhone 7 I
have an iPhone 12 I'm not a [__]
animal anyway
so I bought it as a joke but you know if
something redneck saw it they'd be like
you're goddamn right now America the USA
if you don't America the USA then why
don't you move to North Korea you son of
a [__] get her done you know
and then on this tour I went to Tokyo
Japan Tokyo is a fantastic City it's
about twice the size of Manhattan and
they're the nicest most polite people
ever is a clean well-run City everything
is just like oh and he got the goes I
must say bow I'll give you a great
example I was in a 7-Eleven in downtown
Tokyo in the middle of a busy work day
there's this long line of people
coming in getting something quick to eat
on their lunch break and this is how the
woman gave change to every single person
she had a tray
uh change receipt bowed and said in
Japanese Thank you so much for coming
into our store we appreciate your
business
and everyone reciprocated people weren't
just like yeah yeah whatever they were
like oh thank you so it was so beautiful
I was frozen at how gorgeous this was
and then this Japanese man kind of
accidentally cut in front of me and when
I pointed out to him like excuse me he
was mortified he's like oh I'm so sorry
so sorry I started thinking could you
imagine this [__] in New York City
speaking like a 7-Eleven you know what I
mean Bodega in New York City some big
New Yorker guy cuts in front of you
excuse me oh my [__] bad
I'm so sorry we love tourists in the Big
Apple
perhaps I should commit seppiku ritual
suicide
[Laughter]
to regain my family's honor
go Jets
[Applause]
the other thing I did when I was in
Japan and I've started to do this
anytime I travel internationally and
please do this I started watching their
news because you get a totally different
View and I started watching uh NHK which
is basically like Japan's CNN there's an
English version you can get it online I
highly recommend watching it because
when I first saw it it kind of threw me
off because they do this weird thing
it's called um journalism
uh yeah it's crazy they just talk about
the news and facts and information it's
nuts there's not like a Japanese flag
waving and then that fear ticker like we
have in American Media you know that is
Isis and your kids chocolate milk you
know
there's this old Japanese guy doing
Prime Time news with a weird ear
I'm like he would never be on TV in
America ever
it was it's like wow and I just because
American Media is so bad I don't care
what you watch MSNBC Fox CNN ABC it
doesn't matter art media is designed to
keep us all divided distracted and
Afraid right
yep
they want us fighting red blue black
white male female Boomer gen Z whatever
they want us fighting about whatever man
they're always distracting us with some
[__] like while they're passing some
awful Bill like oh my God Kanye West
said something crazy like no way
everything every story it's always it's
always like a fear angle you know what I
mean and our our journalists they're
they're not journalists they're
infotainers
through these beautiful actors they have
that fake laugh you know that they do
between stories that Segway laugh looks
like it's going to be a wet weekend to
Bob
hopefully not too wet for the big ball
game right down
every story has a fear angle right
everyone has a fear angle what you need
to know about your children and
sprinklers
summertime backyard fun or aquatic death
tool like
sprinklers are killing kids no way
my favorite thing that the media does in
America they'll take whatever the story
of the days we should all be paying
attention to
and they put it next to the dumbest
story ever
new U.N report says America and the
world needs to be off of fossil fuels by
2030 otherwise climate change is
imminent but first
a Florida man whose Bakery has gone to
the dogs
[Laughter]
and then they show like a puppy with
oven mitts on pushing a cake tin into a
stove
[Applause]
those look like some doggone good
muffins so Bob
[Applause]
every winter they do this story every
winter and it's always breaking news
like oh my God a snowstorm hitting the
east coast in the winter no way
every winter it's like who saw that
coming
blizzardzilla snow apocalypse
there's always some guy in the streets
like Linda I'm here in Times Square
there is frozen water coming down from
the sky
meteorologists are calling it snow
it's coming down in an aggressive
war-like manner probably sent here by
Russia or China
so I start watching NHK
watch it because when I watch American
Media I'm mad I'm depressed I'm like we
got no hope when I watch NHK they'll do
these 20-minute human interest stories
that just restore my faith in humanity
they're just beautiful like we're going
to talk to a Kyoto woman about the
ancient art of rice gazing
ricegasing like oh [__] I'm in let's do
this man
some stately Japanese woman comes out in
a kimono first we find the perfect grain
of rice this takes up to 10 years
then we pull a stone out of the river we
put the rice on the stone and we let it
sit and dry in the Sun
then we gaze upon it
contemplating the impermanence of the
universe in the Buddhist tradition much
as the shogunite have done for a
thousand years
holy [__] this is awesome
I'm like have faith in humanity this is
so amazing I love this and meanwhile on
Fox news our gay Mexican socialists
murdering New York City with snow like
no Fox
so the media too they kissed the
billionaires asses because these
billionaires spend tens of million
dollars in marketing money right
remember last summer when Jeff Bezos
threw his [__] rocket around the planet
and media was like this is amazing he
blew a rocket around the planet
here's the actual flight folks it was
four minutes long and barely penetrated
the Earth's atmosphere so I guess Bezos
wanted the whole world to know what his
girlfriend feels
comes off as Rocket they're all high
five and I'm making amazing look you're
doing amazing that stupid cowboy hat you
know he used taxpayer dollars the
richest guy in the history of everything
used our money to fuel that stupid [__]
rocket and then the the journalist
that's no joke man and the journalist
was like oh this opens the doorway for
space tourism this is an actual quote
now for only 23 million dollars you can
fly into outer space Oh 23 million
that's it oh [__] you guys take venmo
[__] yeah let's do this
23 oh great that's all we need the
Richard Branson has a rocket like yeah
23 million so now Rich [__] are
going to fly around a planet that's on
fire that they have the money to fix but
they're too selfish and greedy to do it
yeah
we gotta bring back bullying
I'm telling you not for kids necessarily
but for certain [__] adults like we
should send some meat heads to Silicon
Valley you know what I'm saying just
send some just thugged out UFC guys like
hey basil so it's my rocket now Bezos
thanks nerd just get him in a headlock
hey nerd
you're gonna start paying your employees
union wages with good benefits right
nerd
I mean homelessness right nerd
[Laughter]
the other story they kissed his ass
about last summer I don't remember this
like yeah there's a
bought a new yacht made a new yacht from
scratch it was so big it needed a
support yacht
support yacht Jesus Christ what an
[__] but I get it you know what I
mean I mean if you got a yacht that's
big you're gonna need a support yacht I
mean we're after all where the caviar
and the supermodels gonna go you know
what I mean like I totally get it
remember Betsy DeVos Secretary of
Education under Trump had 10 yachts I
get it you don't want to have the same
yacht in the Caribbean that you have in
the south of France you'll look like a
[__] [__] you know
and you got to get a yacht built from
scratch I mean right you want to drive
around in a used yacht what are you an
animal okay use yeah just saying it
makes me want to vomit it's like oh use
diaper like that's just [__] gross
gross
not too much you guys like yachts
remember too though that when like all
these rich guys are flying into space I
I remember when the space program it
meant something like Nassau we took the
best of the best in America right we
took the we took the best man the best
women we they in the one percent the top
the best scientists the best fighter
pilots the best researchers now just two
Rich dicks can just fly around what's
the NBA finals going to be just Mark
Cuban and Mark Zuckerberg in a game of
horse like
and it's so bad these these you know
these politicians that's why they
control the parties they control the
media they control everything right
these billionaire [__] that's why
every four years we're stuck with voting
for the lesser of two evils right I go
I've been to other countries they'll
have three four five political parties
Coalition governments that get [__] done
we just are it's so bad every four years
the lesser of two evils it's about the
last election 330 million people in this
country
the two best guys we could come up with
Donald Trump and Joe Biden the two best
guys
we scoured the whole country
and we got grab them by the [__] and
sniffing little kids hair all right
awesome
fantastic
good Lord who are we sending to the
Olympics
[Applause]
there's nowhere else in America we would
put up with this lesser of two evil [__]
right or America we want to be the best
right we want to go to the we want our
kids to go to the best schools we want
to live in the best neighbor we want to
have the best jobs we want our teams to
win we want to win the gold medals in
the Olympics we would never tolerate
this imagine if advertisers tried this
the all-new Chevy Malibu
just not as shitty as a Ford Taurus
honey it's date night we need a sitter
for the kids
there's only two babysitters to choose
from
a pedophile and a meth head
I go meth head you got to go meth head
right
kids will have activities you know what
I'm saying
I mean you might come home and one of
them has a prison tattoo but at least
they did some [__]
yeah
so bad people's like well argue with me
ground there's a difference between the
parties okay I'll tell you the
difference
Republicans would skull [__] a puppy to
turn a nickel
the Democrats will skull [__] a puppy
and then put a rainbow flag on it
and go the diversity of puppy skull
[__]
don't bring your kids to Taco guys I
don't know what else to tell you I don't
know how else to break it down
oh these parties are so bad you know and
I just I get I get like mad that
incremental centrism you know they're
getting the Democrats Joe Biden gets
into Power he's like oh remember when he
was running in 2020 in the summer he was
like now is not the time for revolution
where were you during the summer of 20
riots there's food lines people lost
their jobs yeah that's right revolutions
always happen when shits are going great
you know what I'm saying remember the
Civil Rights movements because black
people in the South were being treated
so well they were just like this is
great
and I shudder to think what would happen
if these incremental centrists were
around during like bold times in history
when bold change needed to happen you
know like fdrs famous speech the only
thing we have to fear is everything it's
too hard we can't get it done
Congress is a log Jam you know
JFK we want to put a man on the Moon by
the end of the 60s but I don't think
it's possible
maybe in the 70s or 80s I mean how are
we going to pay for it you know
these gutless leaders today were like if
Joe Biden and Pelosi were around in the
Civil Rights Movement they would have
been like hey Rosa Parks don't move to
the front of the bus it's too
performative
it's a purity test
why don't you do the middle of the bus
in fact start at the back
move up one row at a time
wait a couple years get by partisan
support
that's why we need to smoke weed and
weed needs to be legal in this country
Nationwide I know some states have it
but it needs to be on a federal level it
needs to be completely decriminalized
yep
there's no reason people should be in
prison for smoking a plant and I'm
completely sober you guys I don't I
don't do any of that stuff but I think
this is why we need to you know smoke
weed is because first of all like when
Trump was President I think he would
have been a president better president
if he would have smoked weed
you know instead he just sounded like a
guy coked up at a party trying to rope
you into a business deal
and bro let's do it I got Bitcoin we'll
[__] buy Greenland it'll be awesome
let's start space Force Space Force dude
[__] space force Wanna Be Captain
Captain's what [__] do we'll fly
around we'll bang green chicks like
Captain Kirk perfect Spaceport
it's out of his mind
I remember when the the you know the
Liberals wanted to impeach Trump I was
like I'm glad that didn't happen because
then we would have had president Mike
Pence
yeah exactly what would that have been
just shock the gay out of people and
Outlaw lunch with women
remember when he said I can't have lunch
with my female subordinates what happens
at lunch Mike
[Laughter]
some woman sits down hello Mr Vice
President
how dare you bring your boobs to lunch
[Laughter]
we're out of their minds
like if Trump would have smoked weed
when he was president he wouldn't have
wanted to build a wall around Mexico
he would have just been down at the
border going
we should start a music festival
I mean get Mexican-American bands he's
jamming together [__] body painting
empanadas be [__] sick
[Laughter]
if Biden smoked weed he might you know
remember where he is or
so it's like breaking news like oh that
President finished a sentence today
ladies and gentlemen
ah it's no big deal that the guy in
charge of launch codes has clear
cognitive decline I mean what's the
worst that could happen
[Laughter]
I made fun of both sides if anyone's
offended I [__] took everybody out so
don't worry about it
and if you got offended because I made
fun of your guy you're an occult
and this is why I I think weed should be
legalized like Nationwide because I've
been working in bars and nightclubs
since I was 18 years old which means two
things one I have no marketable skills
thank you
two everything's a joke when you're
when you're two hours a night at the
comedy club either making jokes on stage
or backstage with the other Comics the
other 22 hours out of the day I am
either sleeping or telling myself don't
make that joke don't say that
cops don't find that funny
even in relationships I'm like I love
you I love you too haha tricked you like
everything
everything's a joke
and I like it too because there's a lot
of medical stuff like I'm I'm I like you
know uh holistic medicine whenever I've
tried that because I had a really bad uh
several years ago really bad chronic hip
and back pain
got so bad that the whole left side of
my body was tingling and I called up my
physician I was like hey Doc we should
set up appointment and the left side of
my body's like tingling and in pain do
not ever say left and tingling to a
physician
yeah he lost his [__] he's like oh my
God Graham get yourself to a hospital do
not drive yourself have a friend or get
an ambulance you could be having a
stroke or a heart attack you are on
borrowed time I'm like thanks [__] damn
my buddy's driving me to the the
hospital in L.A I'm flipping out I'm
like well dude if I die you get my
surfboards like I was like
I'm like punching out they run a bunch
of tests on me they're like it's not a
stroke or a heart attack we don't know
what it is so we're gonna order an MRI
okay I'd never had an MRI at that point
the technician goes here's a couple
earplugs about an hour and 15 minutes
just try to sleep through it
yeah that's like exactly you've had an
MRI it's like trying to sleep in a metal
trash can while kids hit it with sticks
but I didn't know this right so I'm
flipping out I'm in the I get in the MRI
the first 30 seconds the machine just
hums you're in basically a tube it's
like a coffin right I'm just sitting
there calming myself down like it's all
right you're gonna be okay it's okay the
machine's just going you're gonna get
through it it's not a stroke or a heart
attack
it's like a fire alarm for your life
like
you're gonna die you're gonna die you're
gonna do a show in a converted mob strip
club in Chicago
[Applause]
so I started doing yoga
yeah I know I'm part of the problem and
before I talk about yoga I just want to
say this real quick about chronic back
pain the worst part about it it's not
the discomfort it's everybody's stupid
suggestions on how to make it better
oh you've had two three years of chronic
back pain have you tried a seat cushion
oh [__] there it is seat cushion okay
yeah
now two years of doctors and
chiropractors and physical therapy and
hundreds of hours of my life and
thousands of dollars because even with
insurance we have a [__] for-profit
Health Care system
foreign
all these tests with all these medical
professionals with Decades of combined
education training and experience and
they all missed seat cushion
do you walk up to blind people and go
have you tried opening your eyes
let the light end
just manifest it
so I started doing yoga
and I love yoga the first yoga class I
went to I was like oh man I could be a
yoga teacher someday
no way there's no way I could ever be a
yoga teacher never in a million years
because like I said I'm a comic
everything's a joke right so if I was a
yoga teacher here's what I would do
I'd get everybody in class I'd play that
music a ding ding ding ding ding
we're like okay guys this is your 60
minutes this is your practice okay this
is your time to connect Mind Body Spirit
okay turn your phones off let go of
everything you got to do outside of the
yoga studio your job your family your
bills your responsibilities let go that
this is your time to reconnect with you
okay our first pose is going to be the
tree pose this leg is going to be our
route and you're going to open up like
this and if you fall out it's okay it's
not a competition
then you're going to raise your arms and
lengthen like this and you don't scrunch
up your shoulders we put so much stress
and tension in our shoulders we're in
our cars we're on our laptops we're on
our phones just lengthen and breathe
okay I'm gonna piss in your mouth
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and remember the second knuckle brings
enlightenment
and no one would question me as a
teacher they'd be in class like did he
just
I heard it wrong I'm crazy
and that's how I know I could start a
cult
thank you for you know watching this the
journey and you've heard tonight you
know I've I've gone through a lot of
sort of Transformations as a person and
one of them is I used to be a huge fan
of the NFL I mean I like watching the
NFL like sports but I used to be a huge
fan I I grew up watching it I played
High School football at Evanston I loved
it I was like I was a Bears fan you know
I saw the Bears winning 85 I was great
you know but it's gotten you know as you
wake up and you start paying attention
how the world works I get a little
bummed out with the NFL man like they
covered up CTE the brain disease that
pissed me off they didn't give a [__]
about domestic violence then there was
videos about it then like oh maybe we
should do something about it they every
before the games it's like a recruiting
thing for War I don't like Wars I told
you you know they should have let
Kaepernick take a goddamn knee they
should have let him take a knee man
they should have gone we're America's
game he has a First Amendment right to
take a knee the people in the stands
have a First Amendment right to boo him
cheer him whatever that's America's game
that's what they should have done and
they didn't it was [__] and I don't
like a lot of their ads man a lot of
their I mean their ads are all like beer
truck steak gun boobs you know
I mean I like boobs but not like Angry
like boobs you know what I mean like the
bacon wrap flag truck boob gun like
so none of them are for me like I said
I'm a vegetarian I meditate I do yoga I
don't drink I'm completely sober I drive
an electric car I'm not making any of
this [__] up man
none of the ads are for me I wish the
NFL would make ads
for hippies like me
but still keep the NFL Style
like hi I'm Chicago Bears head coach and
when I'm making vegan smoothies for my
team
I use blue diamond almond milk
Blue Diamond almond milk the official
organic unsweetened almond milk of the
National Football League
NFL plant-based life
the 2023 Nissan Leaf the official zero
emission vehicle of the National
Football League
plug it in charge it up and hit the open
road up to 123 miles then
charge for another two to three hours
charging May bury in your area then hit
the open road again
great for tailgating yoga retreats
activist rallies
NFL great new deal
Nike and the National Football League
want you to just manifest it
thank you so much Chicago
[Applause]
Palm strike